so i get my question for you is you're
one of the few who decides to retire and
you're
crushing the game you're vip the huge
organization
and what like and i'm saying this
because i like you i care about you it's
like
when you i heard you're coming back i'm
like why man oh i
i think a lot of people had that
reaction but some people were really
excited like myself i'm obviously
excited yeah i'm not saying i'm not
excited
no i can't choose why um
there's no better answer than i just
want to like that's it that's really why
it works for me i just want to
know where i just feel like i can do it
and
i i made sure to go through it
you know kind of that checklist of
things before i decided to like make
that official an announcement what's the
checklist
so basically you know i have had two
kids and i wanted to make sure my body
could still do it that the sport hadn't
passed me by that
i could get in that kind of shape that i
could avoid the injury and that i could
still like
fight or flight you know they talk about
that being an instinct i mean i think
once
a fighter always a fighter but it's one
thing to think that and it's one thing
to go in there and prove it you know
especially after two kids
exactly and and you know four over four
years of being retired you know i
haven't done a ton of sparring in those
four years but
i also think that's going to lead to my
longevity now you know that i'm
a little bit later in my career i'm
smarter i feel like my body is finally
connecting with my
my mindset i'm just more mature i look
at things in a different way
and um i just i so anyways the checklist
was
making sure that i could that all those
things basically
sport hadn't passed me by could i still
do it could i hang could i get on that
level
could i get back into that kind of shape
was there a fight you were watching or
i'm sure you watch ufc so where you
watch something like i can hear those
girls
yeah certain guys yeah yeah that no that
never goes away that's right i don't
know
because i don't want to yeah but in my
head i'm like i could beat that guy
yeah did you still have fights left oh
yeah if i came back they i think i have
four fights left on my contract
got it okay so was there a fight you
were watching like i could beat her
no it just sorry i've always felt that
way yeah but with like
most you know most all of them like i
always just feel that way but
i don't know that's part of being a
fighter i think right you got to kind of
feel that was it
yeah like i think you always got to feel
that way you know know that you can
but again i had to prove that to myself
so
i went back to the gym and i started
training so it's right around the time
that i had my son
so that would be about almost 10 months
ago now that's
when i had the force slow down and it
was just kind of like everything hit a
halt
i knew i was done having kids and i was
like
34. i was like now i think time
started to become relevant i was like i
think i want to make another run at this
and did you tell your man and your
family were they like come on
so i told my obviously i told my man
first i told johnny i said uh
um scooter's coming up to say hi so you
got food for me
um so i told him first and i just wanted
to see what he would think because
obviously you know with the kids it's a
different
ball game like we had a little bit oh
yeah i mean we have so much
it's very overwhelming at times i'm not
gonna lie about it i like my mom with
you i got two toddlers and you know this
weekend
it's so hard i'm home i'm not on tour
and you know it's
grandma grandpa's not around just me and
my girl and we're like man what are we
gonna do
i know if the struggle is real two days
it is just us
it's like we got to figure out what you
do like you're in it absolutely so then
i don't and i'm not familiar with are
you married or just no we're not married
yeah so yeah get there someday so he is
he a fighter is in your fight game
fighter
so he's fought on the ultimate fighter
before um
and now he fights for one championship
okay so he understands it
yeah yeah he understands it definitely
so
yeah he gets it he knows what's going to
have to go into it and of course very
supportive but
he's always my rock because i'm kind of
just like
i don't know like sometimes i get these
ideas and i just
and i just i just go like i've never
been very like i have to be
you know follow this path yeah that kind
of thing it says it invades me
i'm just like fly by the seat of my
pants now i have way more structure in
my life because i have kids but i'm
still that way in my heart
if i feel something if i feel passionate
about it like i'm gonna go with it yeah
and that's why and i'm all in
that's and that's why the comeback was a
lot more well thought out
yes exactly you know because it's like i
knew in my heart what i wanted to do but
i'm also like you know how my man's like
you know well we got to do these things
to make sure like before you before
you go and say something and i didn't
want to put any pressure on myself i
just want to enjoy it i want to come
back and see like what i could do what
kind of shape i could get in and like to
be honest like
if i went in there if i got injured if i
couldn't hang if i couldn't physically
hack it then you know i would have known
and i would have never said anything to
anybody
but i'm sure you're doing pretty well in
training right yeah you're a little
beast
yeah so so then uh when you told one
championship we're like oh come on
because they know you're probably not
gonna be able to i don't know if that's
the way
yeah i don't know if that's the way that
they felt but they but that's not what
they said like when i talked to chautry
who is the ceo and founder of one
championship he was
he was 100 supportive like it's not it's
not very often you find a friend in the
business world that
has you know that your dreams are going
to kind of
counter in in a way what would be
beneficial to them but they're still
going to support you in that
mission you know again my point with one
championship like you said they're
they're supportive of it is like what's
good for you is good for them like the
bigger me should take kids
right associated one championship right
in the vps yeah for them
exactly but i had to put in my 30 days
so
ufc right yeah so i've got like maybe
two weeks left
and then then you can always go back i'm
sure like the doors open i think so i
mean
we left on amicable terms they've been
really good to me i had a good
experience there
like i have no no you know
i mean i don't know which direction i'm
not you know i'm not promising anything
i don't know if i'll continue to work
with ufc after i'm done fighting or if
i'll go back to one
championship but i think doors are open
either way which is
it's just nice to have options and then
uh is there any
opponents in mind or because did i read
that your your
your first flight's gonna be at 45 so is
that the plan
no so it originally i thought about it
because like i'm still breastfeeding my
son and everything like that and i was
like i don't have to diet and cut weight
and like worry about
you know milk supply and all that stuff
but um
i wanted options when i started to look
at the 145 pound division
it's like they let they just let megan
anderson go now there's two women and
amanda's coming back down to 135.
that division i mean there's nothing
there you know what i mean so it's like
felicia spencer and danielle wolf
are fighting but daniel wolf was like i
don't know she's like one or two fights
in mma not very much
i think she's like 101 or want to know
or something and then there's felicia
which i think would be a great fight i
would love to maybe fight her someday
but yeah
i mean if we're not going to have a
division with fights to keep me busy no
longevity there
so you beat felicia what are you gonna
do that's what i guess maybe amanda
nunes if she wants to do it
yeah but you know to be honest i've been
out for four and a half years like
i don't think amanda for my second fight
would be a very smart decision
you know what i mean she's a total
badass and it's great i want to fight
her again but
i want to make sure i do things the
right way and give myself the best
opportunity to win and i don't think
jumping in off
one fight is the best thing to do but
you're such a big name too so it puts
ufc in a tough spot because it's not
like they just toss you some newbie you
know
like calling home was like i'm down for
that like all these dogs because
you're a big dog in this case you're you
know the mount rushmore
female fighting so all of them want
their shot at michael tate now i know
it's funny actually i've been hearing a
lot of but i mean that's great i'll be
the second most hunted woman in the
division
you know there'll be amanda and it'll be
me yep and she doesn't do tune-up fights
though like
like boxing you come out for your life
there's no tune-up they don't they don't
play that
it's very it's sink or swim very much
smashy for misha
yeah because you know what are you big
long career like
literally she's one of the most famous
female fighters of all time so they're
not going to
damn they're not going to show that
they're going to give it like you know
what i mean
i'm not making a comparison to misha but
you look at like even with cm punk
like have fun dude and he just yeah
never fought before
she got absolutely destroyed yeah can we
get him a newer guy
he'll figure it out and they're like and
if he doesn't he doesn't
they want everybody tried and true i
mean they don't want to build up records
and have people be
i don't know that's 34 years old two
kids in four year layoff and you go in
there with the shorts
yeah basically and you ready yeah
absolutely i mean that's i gotta be
that's fine
yeah but so my so the first
woman that i'm that i'm scheduled to
fight is martin renau are you familiar
with her yes
yeah okay no it's not an easy fight
bring her up chin no it's not easy it's
not
she she so this is what this is what
is um what is it
right she's she's at belizean she's 43.
but she she's coming off losses correct
she is so that's the worst part about
this is she's a lot better
than what her record says in my opinion
so she has four losses but they're all
wait no close decisions she's never been
finished
she's lost split decision she's been on
the verge of being a contender a number
of times
she's finished jessica andraj which is
like impossible to do
she triangle choked her then she hurt uh
sarah mcmahon on the feet and triangle
choked sarah mcmahon
that's not easy to triangle choke you
know what i mean it's like so she's got
these
wins that's a weird fight huh because
this i guess
people like oh she's coming out four
losses good that's what i mean it's like
kind of
like easy it's not office it's a it's
not
like it's kind of like worries me
because i'm like people really look at
that and they're just going to see a
wreck i'm like oh four losses i'm like i
don't look at that
at all that way no those losses were all
decision losses and they were pretty
close
like she held her own like she never was
in major trouble
she's never been in major trouble she's
never been finished she's never been
like knocked down like she's never
she's tough she's durable she can do
everything she's a black belt in jiu
jitsu she can strike
you know she can re she can clinch
wrestle um
and when's that fight so let's go down
yeah july 17th
oh that's right yeah you got time yeah
yeah i mean
i got time because i've been doing this
uh i've been training for you know
months now so and then did your manager
call the uc say come back or did you
handle that
no i did i actually was like bugging
dana on instagram and i have no idea why
but he blew off like my first
five dms about wanting to come back just
didn't see him no he saw them that's why
i met him
he didn't respond that's why i messaged
him on instagram because i'm like i'll
be able to see if he read it you know
like i wanted to know like i wasn't
gonna send like just a text message like
i wanna know he saw that [ __ ]
were you nervous when you uh dm'd him
kinda but then i saw and then i got i
started to be like
maybe someone else is running his
account you know you never know like
maybe someone else thought
he's in it on social media but i was
like maybe i don't know maybe there's a
person that's checking it or you know
helps him out with some things and they
opened it and he didn't actually see i
was trying to make up excuses but deep
down i really knew he just was like
ignoring me he probably was like oh
she's not serious that's what i wanted
that's what i think she's finding one
championship and then what what
got over the hump where he started
engaging with you so through dm or text
no it was all through instagram so i
wrote this long message i was like look
i'm not gonna come
back to the us and move my family back
and you know
you know leave one championship is what
i really look like i probably would have
to do right that's what i was
assuming would happen i'm not gonna do
that jump from one tree until i have
another
to make sure so where you know where we
at with this i wanna fight and then he
just said come home
that's all he said in just two weeks oh
damn that's pretty gay but i know right
but i kind of took that as like put your
money where your mouth is like if you're
really serious about wanting to fight
and prove yourself
it makes sense yeah i'm sure he's blown
up all the time
yeah it's all right move home let's see
what happens yeah so i did
you know yeah i'm here dude exactly he's
all right we'll get you a fight then i
came into the office and he's like so
what are you doing here i was like
what do you mean he's like what do you
want i was like i want to [ __ ] fight
yeah
that's what i want to do i came home i
know right here i am
and he just still was kind of like okay
like he was still kind of like a
you know why he's like are you not
making good money i think that was the
other thing maybe he was concerned about
me being desperate
right that it washed up misha tate was
going to come back and desperate to feed
her family kind of thing and just
get my ass kicked and take a paycheck
and leave you know
um but i was like no i really want to
fight i was like okay well wait what i
was like probably 45 so i don't have to
worry about cutting weight or just walk
in fat and happy
and he was like okay um
what did he say he said well oh he said
45 is a rematch with amanda and i said
so is 35.
like either way i'm gonna get to it you
know what i mean so
i just uh i was like that's fine with me
that's what i want anyways at the end of
the day like i want to fight her again
and i want to
i want to do it i want to be the baddest
woman on the planet again and then
the since you left you know especially
four years ago that 35 is stacked
it's a bit of a difference it is well it
is but a lot of the women that
when i left are still on the top so
that's why another reason why i
definitely don't feel like
you know the sports like quote-unquote
pass me by i mean holly you've seen her
get a you know
numerous title shots again she's still
talking about wanting to make another
run at it
i mean juliana pena we grew up in this
sport together she's gonna fight
you know for the title next like a lot
of the women marion renault right this
is a retirement fight
granted but i mean she's been in the ufc
close to as long as i have
um i would say cats and gano obviously
she went over to bellator but she's
still in it she's still winning fights
right
these are women that uh cyborg amanda
amanda too
you know to be honest yeah i mean yeah
she so come back like crazy
yeah but those are all women that were
in my in a better in my hair
you know she's been around forever holly
holm doing this sarah mcmahon
pena sarah mcmahon yeah
yeah they're all doing it so you know
it's a it's a good mixture but a lot of
them are still from my what i would
consider my generation of fighting and
they're still doing great things and
still holding
top five spots and top 10 spots mostly
all of them actually
um so yeah i definitely think like i
still have time and
was there any uh idea or was there any
attempt to
get released from the ufc contract so
you can find one championship just to
make it easy
well i think this is route right yeah
that would have been the easiest route
but i knew that they weren't going to do
that just based on we tried to do a
grappling match with one championship
and they ex nade that real quick dana
didn't like that you're too you're too
big of a name
yeah so i guess i mean that's what it is
and to be fair like the uf
the ufc had so much to do with elevating
my brand
correct you know i think people cared a
little bit coming from strikeforce you
know ron and i had that great fight it's
one and and
you know gina and cyborg since that time
kind of moved forward
and it was a big part of that movement i
think people started to care about it
but
it was still a lot of hardcore fans you
know hardcore fans really cared it
wasn't so much
like it is now mainstream yeah when i
think of uh women's fighting you talk
about the pioneers it's like gina
cyborg rhonda and you and then amanda
you know came on late and obviously
she's the dominant face of the
woman's fighting all women's fighting so
there's like you five are in mount
rushmore
yeah and you know amanda i don't think
she was too much behind us though
you know she's i think she's 32 but she
just didn't get noticed
until she changed camps and then changed
camp than the maturity right like
you look at that fight with cats in
ghana right she had she was beating
[ __ ] out of cat and just kind of you
know got tired and then got beat and i
think she learned from that now she's
just this
absolute dominant champ man yeah
dominant yeah
i think what's good for you and your
advantages you knew her before that
these girls find her now
like megan and stuff like that you know
they see her as this
the goat the lion you don't see that no
i just like no that's
exactly and i've seen her losing an
invicta oh sarah delegate
i'm pretty sure it was saturday leo
peter but uh um
yeah i've seen her lose before i mean i
know she has her weaknesses and stuff
which i think is such a big advantage
because a lot of those girls like you
know i love mikaner so
i think she was beat before it even
started i agree completely agree
she looked like her eyes got like this
big as soon as the bell went and amanda
started marching across the way and she
was just kind of like ah
and i was like well i will not be like
ah when i fight her i promise you
that like you know i can't i can't
promise victory you guys but i can
always promise that i'll bring a hell of
a fight and i'm not scared of any woman
on this planet
is there besides her is there any other
fights redemption fights or anything
like that you're looking for
um i wish i could run it back again with
kat but
she's over bellator right now so that's
kind of just been a great fight
yeah i would really like to to run it
back with that
um you know and then i i think i'll end
up fighting holly again it's not really
something i'm like gunning down because
i beat holly so it's not like you know
you know like gotta have it but i'm sure
she'll be one of those six fights though
yeah i'm sure she will be at some point
i'd love to fight jermaine that's one
that i've never i never got the
opportunity to fight her
so i'm pretty sure you're gonna you're
gonna win this one then you're looking
at those those top
top women exactly you're looking at you
know top three and i think jermaine is
yeah she's one she's one holly holm's
two i'm interested in
janna too because i think yana and
jermaine those would be
fun fights for me those women are both
you know ranked really high and
and um you know yana she's improving
every fight that i see her she's getting
better yeah she's getting a lot better
she's got
good striking she you know she's fought
cyborg so i know she's not scared you
know she's not scared to fight people
and she comes to fight she gets better
with her wrestling been seeing her take
people down and
you know land her ground and pound and
stuff so i think that'd be a good one
too how about that
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this wrote a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
on i'm just saying dude grab that mic
son